oh
[Musique]
personne
alors qu'est ce que c'est mais qu'est ce
qu'on dit au revoir hier à mirabel j'ai
regardé
et là c'est une surprise qui tue je
m'appelle ulysse je suis le marchand de
sable et ils amis de tous les enfants du
monde et tous les petits enfants et
petits-enfants noah oui des petits
enfants noirs des petits chinois comme
des petits indiens
chaque soir je survole la terre entière
pour voir si tous les petits enfants vos
sagement se coucher et en même temps
je sais mon sable
qu'est-ce qu'il fait ensemble ils
donnent envie aux petits enfants d'aller
se coucher et vous mes deux petits amis
comment vous appelez-vous je m'appelle
dit oui et moi me ramène petit louis et
mirabel quel âge avez-vous moins cinq
ans est ce que vous êtes bien sage
oui il vient si vous êtes toujours bien
sage
je viendrai vous voir chaque soir mossu
n'ayez pas peur les enfants lui ces gros
ours mon fidèle compagnon
il m'accompagne dans tous mes voyages je
suis le vieux copain de tous les enfants
qui me connaissent bien
oui je suis gros mais je suis aussi très
gentil c'est moi qui embête au lit les
garnements qui ne veulent pas y aller
roux
il se fait tard allons au dodo pour nous
donner aujourd'hui c'est la lutte
année annonce que viendra nous voir tous
les soirs et qui nous racontera des
histoires bon quand vous aurez été bien
sage aller boire
[Musique]
enfin bonjour au revoir au revoir
une bonne chose de faite
[Musique]
ça y est le fait vous voyez
petit louis et mirabel sont maintenant
couchez vous tous aussi à aller vite au
lit et si vous êtes très sage
nous reviendrons vous voir demain soir
bonne nuit des enfants
[Musique]
oh
on
ah ah
enfin
bonsoir mes petits amis vous savez petit
louis et mirabel sont allés au cirque ça
d'après midi ils ont vu des tas de
choses amusantes des clowns acrobates de
grosses baie des singes des girafes des
tigres et même des lions que de bruit
mais qu'est ce qui se passe dans cette
maison mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
rose ours vient alors d envie de voir
nos jeunes couples
mais m
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça a sion
et bouillon lot coucher moi j'ai les
baies la ion sera d'en manger
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fait revivre les en auraient ils n'ont
jamais se battre
ulysse ne va pas être content du tout à
ça non allons au lit et en vitesse
lille un garnement et ne recommencez
plus à ce bac sans rien faire à moi
[Musique]
alors à leur art ou la flore tout démoli
garnements faut tout ranger
le
[Musique]
que le travail coup garnements
vous voyez ils ont été très vilain ils
se sont battus et s'il recommence
nous ne reviendrons plus les voir bonne
nuit les petits enfants embrassez vos
parents allez vite vous coucher et à
demain bonne nuit
en
oh
[Musique]
où
en
[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis mes petits amis
nous avons fait un très long voyage
aujourd'hui nous sommes bien fatigué ou
là mais petit louis et mirabel nous
attendent
ils ont été très gentils et nous sommes
revenus les voir ainsi qu'on leur avait
promis hier
ouais et vous aussi des enfants
je suis sûr que vous avez été très sage
n'est ce pas qu'en penses-tu gros ours
oui lisons tous les deux rue migneault
j'en suis bien content voyons un peu ce
que fabriquent nos deux petits copains
ils ont l'air fort tranquille descend
voir ce qui se passe
gros ours ouais ouais up la pompe au pot
commun pour eux ils ont tous être mignon
nous sont ils donc bonjour bonjour tu
connais l'histoire la petite souris
une petite souris que tu es belle
histoire d'un petit sou et verte
en fait la raconter et toi tu dois
essayer de vous attraper oliva une
souris verte ainsi qu'aux halles en
herbe
j'ai la crainte par là que je la montre
à ces messieurs les attrape l'europe
mais où elle s'occupe donc cette coco
guy lacombe il quand il a donné ce serat
l'escargot tout haut dominique m'a dit
[Musique]
si tu me vois pas trop je rives
allez bonne nuit les enfants et dormait
vite manoeuvrer l'histoire
[Musique]
voilà furent retard sur le retard ou
blanc
[Musique]
allons allons dépêche-toi gros jours en
route
jory nous avons encore une longue
tournée a fait jeu dur
allons allons oui bonne nuit petit louis
bony mirabel
[Musique]
bonne nuit les petits amis allez vite
vous coucher et faites de beaux rêves
à demain demain bonne nuit
[Musique]
où
oh
on
en
au soir les enfants petit louis et
mirabel ont été vraiment très très
mignon aujourd'hui ils sont allés se
promener avec leurs parents et ensuite
ils ont entièrement ranger leur chambre
et vous avez vous été bien sage
oui et bien gros jour vous a amené ainsi
qu'à nos deux petits copains une belle
surprise
vasic ressources gilbert facile d'une
seule main encore surprise
asseyez vous aujourd'hui pour tous les
enfants qui voter des sages fois-ci et
de belles histoires
[Musique]
ulysse va vous raconter l'histoire de pi
corps est la poule blanche attention la
séance commence
[Musique]
par une belle matinée d'été dame
picorettes la poule blanche picorer des
grains sous une rame et de petits pois
quand une cosse puis tomba sont là que
avec une telle force qu'elle cru que le
ciel allait tomber
alors elle pensa qu'elle devait aller
avertir le roi et elle s'en alla
sautillant sautillant sautillant et
rencontra chanteclair lecoq
où vas-tu comme ça picorettes la poule
blanche au chanteclerc dit elle le ciel
va tomber et je vais le dire au roi
j'irai avec toi dit chanteclair et les
voilà sautillant sautillante sautillant
chanteclair et picorettes et ils
rencontrèrent clopinant le canard et le
canard le redis où allez vous comme ça
chantecler et picorettes il dira au
clopinant le ciel va tomber et nous
allons le dire au roi
j'irai avec vous dis clopinant il
dévoila sautillant sautillant sautillant
clopinant chanteclair et picorettes et
ils rencontrèrent dandinait tu dois
grise
tournez-vous comme sa copine au chaud
tout le corps et leur demanda loi au
dandy net
le ciel va tomber et nous allons le dire
au roi jurer avec vous dit andy net et
dévoila sautillant sautillant sautillant
dans dînette clopinant chanteclair et
picorettes et ils rencontrèrent compères
le renard et le renard le redis où allez
vous comme ça
clopinant andine est chantée claire et
picorettes aux compères le renard le
ciel va tomber et nous allons le dire au
roi
venez avec moi dans dînette clopinant
santéclair et picorer
je vous montrerai le chemin qui va au
palais du roi mais ils répondirent au
nom qu'on perd le renard nous trouverons
bien le chemin tout seul et nous n'avons
pas besoin de vous ils arrivèrent au
palais du roi le roi se mit à rire de
leur naïveté mais il les remercia
beaucoup beaucoup et il ordonna à chacun
un très très beau cadeau
à cette échelle la remercie alors les
enfants ça vous a plu
[Musique]
eh bien elle évite aux totaux voilà pas
trop j'arrive
si vous voulez mirabel en voie rapide
[Musique]
allons allons dépêche-toi au jour nous
allons être en retard alors onu et les
amis rendormez vous vous faites de beaux
rêves et à demain bonne nuit
[Musique]
en
bonsoir les enfants décidément mirabel
et p'tit louis sont de plus en plus sage
j'espère que vous aussi vous faites
plaisir à vos parents et alors j'y vais
et d'accor asie gros ours mais ne soit
pas trop long un second prix souhaité
rocquemont toutes les caisses que ça
mais qu'est ce que c'est une très belle
histoire mais quelle histoire que je
m'en vais vous ont des causes que je
venais près deux mois estime jack et le
haricot
il y a très longtemps vivait dans un
petit village le pauvre
son fils le petit ver qu un jour sa
maman dit à jako o mais notre vieille
vache au marché et vend là nous pourrons
acheter de quoi manger
jacques au parti en chemin il rencontre
un homme qui lui offrit un sac de
haricot en échange de sa vache jacquot
accepta sa maman entra dans une grande
colère petit idiot que peux tu faire de
ces haricots elle lança le sac par la
fenêtre et pleura longtemps longtemps
notre jacotot prise dallas se coucher
sans avoir mangé
le lendemain le soleil brillait jacou
ouvrit la fenêtre et vie quant à ricco
avait fermé et poussé pendant la nuit et
montait vers le ciel en un clin d'oeil
jacovella à cheval sur une branche et
disparus dans les nuages tandis que sa
maman affolée la plaie en vain chacko
arriva devant un très beau château avec
de grandes tours
toc toc toc il frappa à la porte
une dame lui triade derrière la porte
va-t'en petit garçon car le mato de ce
château est un ogre qui te mangera s'il
te vois les ja cours entre quand même et
se cacha sous la table l'offre freud
fille l'ogre mais la serveuse lui servit
très vite en coq rôti un gigot et un
gros gâteau l'ogre mange à tous puis il
prit arbre magique dit qu'à sa poule de
bombes et la poule pour 10,6 tout
bonnement puis
la harpe se mit à jouer une belle games
berceuses et langres se mit à ronfler
jacquot sorti de sa cachette et remporta
avec lui la poule et la harpe pour les
robes des à sa maman mais la harpe se
mit à crier au secours au secours
l'ogre serait vega avait couru derrière
jacko jacko descendit le long du haricot
chéran pris une hache et coup pas très
vite le pied de l'arbre le giro disparu
jacquot et sa maman vécurent très
longtemps riche et heureux grâce à la
poule et la harpe merveilleuse et voilà
l'histoire et finir mais dites nous
comment ils sont devenus riches et
comment ils furent heureux parce que
chaque fois que j'avais besoin d'argent
les jouets de l'art et la boule pourbaix
les oeufs en or dont il avait besoin
pour vivre
allons les enfants ou lit en vitesse
ulysse m'a bien recommandé de ne pas
trop traîner
voilà un patron voilà j'arrive j'ai
encore trouvé moyen de mettre en retard
[Musique]
voilà rien renier petit louis owni
mirabel bonne nuit tous les enfants en
dormez vous vivez nous reviendrons vous
voir demain demain boni
[Musique]
oh
bonjour les petits enfants nous
attendons lycée gros source
oui ils reviennent ce soir d'un long
voyage aussi plus avons bien ranger la
maison émis chaque chose à sa place
[Musique]
tient même un nom pourquoi j'aurais
juste ma cravate
j'espère qu'une idée mompati du mouza
regarde si lui c'est acheter des gâteaux
septembre où hugh laurie sera content
qu'est ce qui est gros moins drôle oui
voilà
[Musique]
mais oui les enfants
nous revoilà je vous avais promis que
nous reviendrions bientôt et vous le
voyez nous sommes revenues aléas les
ressources des 100 petit louis mirabel
sont sûrement impatient de revoir va
vite leur dire bonsoir à tout de suite
pas trop je descends de sport a tout de
suite
bobo je suis content de vous voir
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est un collier avec des
flancs ouais avec des fleurs
[Musique]
il
où
[Musique]
matelly loi on est même allé jusqu'à
tata tahiti ouais parfaitement et
qu'elle souhaitait nous en rapporte et
regarder des belles fleurs des beaux
gosses à l'époque et je vous aurez
toutes les photos que nous avons fait
pendant notre voyage vous voyez lit ce
matin oddo revient lui demande où est
soignée par qui valent pas non mais 8
mai n'est pas dans la lumière la nuit
votre appel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit tous mes petits amis nous
sommes très content d'être venu vous
voir car vous savez vous nous avez
beaucoup manqué mais nous avons été très
heureux de recevoir toutes les belles
lettres que vous nous avez écrites elles
nous ont fait très plaisir
alors en route nord à demain les enfants
bonne nuit dormait vite
à deux pas
[Musique]
oh
bonsoir les petits amis je crois que
mirabel et p'tit louis attendent gros
ours et qu'ils sont très pressés de le
voir ce soir je dois leur montrer
l'album de photos de notre voyage au
mais ne restent pas plus de cinq minutes
tu as compris gros ours
[Musique]
les 90 ans tata pour 20 les fous tout
votre voyage je vais vous les montrez
venez venez on va s'asseoir là bas il y
en a beaucoup elles sont belles venez
venez vite et l'accord oui oui vous
allez voler oui oui vous allez voir
elles sont très belles assiettes
la voilà voilà les enfants maintenant
nous partons en voyage avec unissent à
vous pas trop les dessins se voit qu'ils
aient fait lorsque nous sommes partis au
mois de décembre il faisait très froid
le ciel était tout gris et nous n'avons
rencontré qu'un pauvre petit oiseau
perdu qui cherchait son nid car il avait
très faim nous sommes arrivés dans un
pays plein de jolies fleurs qui sentait
très bon et le petit oiseau qui était
venu avec nous sur notre nuage est
descendu pour picorer les fleurs et se
faire un beau petit nid avec les brins
d'herbe qui l'avait ramassée
mais gros jour c'est moi nous avons
continué notre long voyage
nous avons alors survolé une mer immense
qui étaient tout bleus mais nous n'avons
pas vu de poisson ouais non ça n'avait
rien mais non mais non il n'y avait pas
de poisson ils s'étaient tous caché au
fond de l'eau soyons pas trop enlevée
bon d'accord il y avait un poisson nous
sommes arrivés au bout de la mer et nous
avons survolé un très beau pays où il y
avait des arbres qui avaient l'air de
danse et tout à coup au coin d'une
rivière
on a vu un énorme crocodile qui avaient
des dents terrible et gros ours a eu
très peur ou là
heureusement que plus loin il y avait un
lyon très gentil qui est même venu nous
donner la patte et qui nous a présenté à
toute sa petite famille
car il avait deux bons petits enfants et
aussi beaucoup beaucoup d'amis des
zèbres très amusant et une grosse maman
rhinocéros qui se promenait avec son
bébé est seul dans un coin le seigneur
kids comme gros ours avait très peu
d'eau nous avons dit au revoir au joli
petit chaos là et avons continué notre
voyage et nous sommes réveillés un jour
dans un pays où il n'y avait que de la
glace et de curieuses aux gens habillés
de noir et blanc nous ont reçus très
aimablement c'était messieurs et
mesdames les pingouins et voilà que tout
d'un coup dans toute cette glace je ne
savais pas que grosos avait un riche
cousin qui faisait le tour du monde en
automobile mais malgré tous ses nombreux
amis qui étaient très gentils avec nous
et qui ne savaient que faire pour nous
faire plaisir
petit louis et mirabel nous manquait
vraiment de trop et nous sommes revenus
aussi vite que possible et retrouver et
vous retrouvez vous tous aussi et voilà
qui entre bien partir en voyage vous
allez partir en voyage en allant vite au
dodo et en faisant de beaux rêves à
l'eau au lit merci c'est un très beau
voyage
merci de nous revoir les enfants admis
van
[Musique]
à demain petits enfants embrasser vite
vos parents et en dormez vous bien
sagement
au revoir petit louis au revoir mirabel
bonne nuit bonne nuit
adobe 1
[Musique]
en haut
bonsoir les amis oh mais tout me paraît
très calme ce soir du silence j'ai bien
l'impression que p'tit louis et mirabel
sont déjà couchés
je mets au dormantes et on ne fait pas
trop de bruit pour ne pas les réveiller
ou vous pouvez me faire confiance pas
trop bon
balou et à personne le don doit savoir
qu'il a tenté de tourner nos regards
regarde le poisson que j'attrape et fait
attention contient beaucoup toulon n'est
pas la mer sur un bateau
olalala que d'eau j'ai attrapé le
poisson vous avez rencontré avec une
liste non seulement qu'il est pris et
nous fait moi aussi je te dis que c'est
moi bien je me calme toi tu es un
menteur je ne veux pas noyer les bras
je vais monter dans le bateau
me voilà dans le bateau
[Musique]
moment pour son allure porter attention
là il est reparti dans l'eau et il est
très content d'être dans l'eau d'imagés
il fait aussi dodo quand il est à bien
non à côté vous et il ne faudra pas
faire de bruit
1 pour ne pas le réveiller
[Musique]
allons bonne nuit ni petit poisson rouge
qui jaillit à huy mini revel
[Musique]
ouais
endormez vous vite mirabel et p'tit
louis et toi aussi petit poisson rouge
et vous les petits enfants allez vite
vous coucher et si vous êtes bien sage
nous reviendrons sans faute pouvoir
demain soir boni à demain bonne nuit
[Musique]
à demain
non
en
[Musique]
les petits enfants bonjour comme vous
vous en doutez mirabel et son frère
petit louis ont été très occupés
aujourd'hui ils sont allés avec leur
maman chercher de la nourriture pour
leurs jolis petits poissons rouges car
il est très gourmand et ne veut pas
manger n'importe quoi ou lourd mais
finalement ils lui ont trouvé de la
délicieuse poissonnet la boisson des
taureaux pourrait bien goûter samoa hop
la pop au pot
[Musique]
dim un bon jour nous vient voir angers
une jolie petite maison le ramenant à
mort avec sa vie des cailloux et ce
matin j'ai mis de la loire pendre son
mari comment vous ne lui avait pas mis
des des coquillages
pourquoi fermer parce que les poissons
saem les coquillages dans tout le monde
sait ça attendez je vais voir dans ma
poche là dans ma poche au fond de ma
poche
j'en ai ramené des très beaux de tahiti
à aller voilà nos douze ans vous allez
me faire mal
là encore ce joyau mois moi je mets
encore ce petit verre voilà ça suffit
évidemment on ne sait pas comment il
s'appelle toit sont peut-être
[Musique]
donald mickey minnie en disant c'est un
achat d'or aux jo tu es bien dire mais
on dirait qu'il a sommeil ils pas tous
bons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui et je vais le faire voilà c'est fait
au revoir les enfants dorment bien oscar
pièce car n'est ce pas
[Musique]
et bien voilà ce joli petit poisson
rouge s'appelle oscars je suis sûr qu'il
dort déjà et que vous n'allez pas tarder
à faire comme lui
bonne nuit des enfants embrassez vos
parents est allé sagement vous coucher à
demain adobuzz
[Musique]
mon
ouf nous voilà quand même arrivé au
j'avais très peur d'être en retard car
nous avons eu beaucoup à faire pendant
la journée mais heureusement les vents
nous ont été favorables
avez vous été très sage aujourd'hui
oui et bien tant mieux au petit louis et
mirabel ont été eux aussi très très
mignon et gros jour leur a préparé un
joli jeu très simple jeu très amusant
j'y vais pas trop vas-y nounours ah et
en bracelet bien fort de ma part ou aux
côtés sur moi patron ou
[Musique]
bonjour je viens jouer avec noah cash
car oui à cache cache ou bien chacun
sait pourquoi pas au jeu de l'ado c'est
bien plus drôle dit c'est comment voilà
voilà
la voilà la no vous fermez les yeux
je le pose quelque part où tout le monde
peut le voir et quand vous ouvrez les
yeux
vous devez le chercher le premier qui a
trouvé à gagner allons allons tourner le
dos et fermez les yeux et quand je
dirais ça y est le jeu commence vous
aussi les petits enfants qui nous
regardaient et égouttés fait comme petit
lou ye mirabel fermé les yeux pendant
que nounours cash l'anneau et quand il
ira
ça y est vous pourrez regarder et le jeu
commencera
[Musique]
m où je vais encore un petit moment elle
ne regardez pas voilà
attention le jeu va commencer quand vous
serez prêt de l'ado je vous dirais c'est
chaud attention ça y est 3 ces deux là
sont de plus en plus froid tiens tiens
il ya un petit vent chaud qui sinon les
enfants on joue on ne se dispute pas du
reste il est très tard tant mieux mais
maintenant il faut vite aller dormir
allons au dodo
un jour encore demain bien sûr que vous
pourrez jouer la bonne nuit les enfants
non je me rappelle ma ce mois qui
cacherait un no et moi je le trouverai
[Musique]
bonnut et petit louis bonne nuit petite
mirabelle bonne nuit mes petits amis si
vous essayez de jouer à l'anneau vous
verrez c'est très drôle et vous vous
amuserez beaucoup moi moi j'aime bien ça
c'est bon jeu favori allons allons
allons en route gros qu'on perd à demain
bonne nuit
bonne nuit à demain
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants ont dit non non non
non non non non j'ai les mains gelées
il fait très froid dans le ciel ou wii
ou la mois moi je descend vite vite 8 me
réchauffer chez b petit copain petit
louis et mirabel au où il ne traîne pas
trop nounours gros sinon je pars sans
toi ouais ouais je suis chez son
coiffeur
asseyez-vous à me joindre à vous je vous
crois que j'en ai fini monsieur petit
louis haut
voilà monsieur vous êtes vous voulez une
friction
oui s'il vous plaît mademoiselle me
rappelle je voudrais de l'autre colonne
qui sent bon
et voilà c'est bien et ça fait combien
mademoiselle cette fois monsieur et
n'oubliez pas le service eau toujours le
char vie voilà merci monsieur jeu
suivant il a de la force et votre
assiste aux messieurs brouillent chaque
fois une mise en scène un défrisage ma
foi ce qu'il y a deux lieux
j'ai beaucoup de sous là ça suffit
c'est beau
[Musique]
maintenant l'arrêt aux milices non sur
la côte du bourg pitié peau dorée au
milieu sur le compte et enfin je
souhaite une autre
[Musique]
que le bleu voilà patron
j'arrive vous êtes de vilains garnements
allez vous coucher tout seul et tout de
suite
je suis très fâché avec vous oh là là
c'est pas joli pas content du tout
content du tout du tout du tout on note
l'ofs l'honneur
[Musique]
petit louis et mirabel ont été très
méchant il ne faut jamais se battre
même quand on joue et gros jour c'est
bien triste
il a beaucoup de peine tu es dans un bel
état gros jours ci souhaitait très
coquin et bien pour les punir
nous ne viendrons pas les voir demain
soir viendra pas mes 6 ans âge
nous reviendrons après demain viendra
bonnut des enfants produits embrassez
vos parents et aller vite au lit ouais
mais surtout ne vous battez pas bon
c'est promis à bientôt
à bientôt
[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis square
hier nous ne sommes pas venus vous voir
vous savez pourquoi
mais j'espère aujourd'hui petit louis et
mirabel ont été gentils et vous avez
vous été sage répondre aux horreurs
allô allô allô allô allô allô allô pièta
l'appareil
bonjour bien rappelle bonjour dit oui ce
sont nos deux petits coquins à noël ou
all alors qu est ce qu on entend balle
allô allô retour aux sources
tu sais maintenant on est très sage
honteux dans de l'auteur soit dit tu
viens de dire bonsoir je te plonge
jusqu'à minutes caméra de dos il tu
reviens à venir il a dit oui et dessins
[Musique]
bonjour et coutumes nos chéris on était
méchant d'autres jours mais tu sais
c'est fini on ne se bat plus jeune que
moi aussi les enfants
je vous aime ou on fait une petite ronde
et on va se coucher
d'accord d'accord d'accord on doit
picotin oui
[Musique]
picotte mami a chanté pas plus gros
qu'un soulèvement est pourri comme à
paris 6 pierre you do we made for de
douilles au loto ne contenait pas de
loup à nous de ne pas l oms oui oui oui
patron c'est ulysse des banques si vous
êtes sages oui ils sont déjà au lit elle
vous dise
benoît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
onu mirabel bonne nuit petit louis
bonne nuit tous les petits enfants aller
vite au dodo est faite de doux rêves
plat allons allons de l'ours en route
allons vite nous coucher nous aussi à
demain à demain les enfants à demain
[Musique]
en en
en
[Musique]
bonsoir les petits enfants cadeddu fait
aujourd'hui vous avez préparé des
déguisements
oh c'est une très bonne idée oui mais
pourquoi voyons une niche c'est pour
mardi gras
mais c'est vrai je vais oublier
je me demande si mirabel et p'tit louis
y ont pensé
je m'en vais voir ça de plus près vous
mais dépêche toi gros remous ne traîne
pas comme d'habitude non bob non mes
propres propos
[Musique]
oui je peux plus passer tranquille voilà
attention à mai aps le minimum mais
pourquoi c'est faire toutes ses plumes
assez pour mardi gras
je m'habille en indien et moi en chicane
quatre gros sous ce label dentelle noire
que je vais mettre sur mes cheveux et le
beau père
et
je trouve pas que ce soit joli os ou
mois par mois j'aurai chapeau d'indiens
aussi difficile à fabriquer tu sais là
on pique les plumes comme ça là la nôtre
ici encore comme ça comme ça là oui
j'aurais aussi des boucles d'oreilles
encore une liste ils m'ont toujours bien
que nos pensées voilà là là parce qu'il
se fait quoi
hp qui trouvera pas un instant qu'ils
créent les plumes attaque la wii au la
nuit dans le trop chaud quand je suis
brûlé tu veux toujours faire le pas je
préfère jeter c'est joli c'est lui
peut-être que ça m'irait au nom repas
style oui oui c'est vrai o o
il est très tard
allons c'est assez pour aujourd'hui vous
finirez demain matin all i will we way
vient
[Musique]
et toi nono commenter ce cas d'élise et
en secret vous verrez ce que vous verrez
bien peu plus tôt le plus vite possible
bonne nuit les enfants bonne nuit namo
ce we only mirobolants bien
[Musique]
bonne nuit petit indien
bonne nuit petite gitane bonne nuit les
petits enfants je suis sûr que demain
vous aurez tous deux très beaux
déguisements allons voir allons-nous
nours en route
oui toi aussi tu dois préparer ton
costume au port sûr que je dois le
préparer je leur ai promis
embrassez vos parents heureux et allez
vite vous coucher bonne nuit à demain à
demain
[Musique]
où